a year after president trunk to trunk
office hundreds of thousands of women
again took to the streets in massive
demonstrations now many are looking to
turn the energy of protest into actual
power a record number of women are
running for office this year and it's
the topic of the Time magazine cover
story The Avengers here to talk about it
is time national correspondent Charlotte
alter Charlotte good morning welcome
thank you so much for having me let's
talk about the numbers first of all how
big are they extraordinary I mean there
is a pink wave coming the number of
women Democrats challenging Republican
incumbents for House seats is up 350
percent in an ordinary actually the last
two year period from 2015 to 2016
Emily's lists about 900 women reach out
about running for office in the last one
year they've heard from from almost
30,000 which is a huge jump well let's
let's talk about the catalysts that have
driven women to do this you liken it to
citizens enlisting in a sudden war
what's taking these women out of there
sort of like happy professional personal
lives and into the political arena yeah
well so what's interesting is that I
think Trump caused these women to March
but it's they're Republican members of
Congress who are kind of providing the
incentive for them to run most of the
women that I spoke to said that they
were absolutely enraged not only just by
the actions of the Trump administration
but by their Republican representatives
who were trying to take away their
health care that was the number one
issue that women cited in in their
reason for running and not only trying
to take away their health care but also
then cancelling town halls refusing to
meet with constituents and not not kind
of stepping up and and and listening to
the people that they're supposed to
represent a lot of women said some
version of you know what I can do a
better job than that gosh yeah it's
interesting because when the March
happened and we were talking about this
in the break a lot of people thought
well this is a really impressive turnout
but what's gonna happen next
something did happen absolutely I mean
there was a ton of skepticism after the
March last year and it was
it was interesting to me because it's
the it was the largest single-day
demonstration in American history and it
was almost in it was led entirely by
women and it was mostly women who were
marching and yet there was so there was
a lot of hmm what are they really gonna
do about it
one thing that I thought was interesting
about this year's March is that every
single person I spoke to I covered the
March last weekend said that they had
been if they weren't running they were
organizing if they weren't organizing
they were donating if they weren't
donating they were voting and
encouraging everybody around them to
vote what are you talking one of the
things we talked about when we have
previously looked at the dearth of women
candidates as women feel like they need
to be qualified they need to check all
the boxes before they run the same
feeling is not true for men this year
that seems to have changed in large part
because of Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump absolutely this is a total
paradigm shift in the way women think
about their own qualifications for
running for office I think like you said
there are all these studies that show
that men will go for a job when they
meet 60% of the qualifications most of
the qualifications women feel like they
can only put themselves forward if they
check all the boxes and I think what we
saw in last in the 2016 election was you
saw a woman who many women perceived as
being extremely qualified certainly the
only woman ever to come close to the
presidency running against a man who had
never held public office had never
served in any government role and it
made a lot of women think to themselves
and and then she lost so it made them
think to themselves if Hillary Clinton
was the most qualified woman ever to run
for president and she lost to somebody
like Donald Trump maybe all those
qualifications aren't actually that
important very interesting there are 12
women in the Senate who are up for
re-election 11 or Democrats are the
Republicans answering with female
candidates absolutely I mean they're
there this is a really tough map for
Democrats in 2018 most of the energy is
certainly on a Democratic side but there
absolutely are a lot of women
Republicans running I mean women women
Republicans are there it's it's not as
if this is a this is all on the Democrat
side there are certainly a lot
Republican women especially women who
are gonna be challenging Democratic
incumbents but but the surge of energy
the surge of of women who are like
putting themselves forward who would
have never ever considered it before is
largely on the progressive side well
women make up half the country only a
fifth of Congress and 12% of the
governor's seats so perhaps a
rebalancing of the scales is overdue
Charlotte alter from time thanks so much
thanks for having me